[Music]
his slams bent thousands of rims but the
celebrity life's not for him no finally
shaquille dunks on celebs who act like
punks shaquille o'neal a man known for
being tall larry i heard that says he's
retiring from celebrity status if only i
could do the same but why deprive the
fans
in a recent interview the nba hall of
famer basically said most celebs are
nuts and that he's had enough
celebrities are crazy i don't want to be
in that category they are they're going
freaking insane
don't call me that anymore these people
are out of their freaking mind
how they treat people what they do what
they say but just because i made it
don't mean i'm bigger than you
it's because i made it don't mean i'm
smarter than you it's because i have
more money than you don't mean that i'm
better than you i've never been that way
and i never will be that way so i don't
want to be in that category with people
so like this i don't want these these
celebrities are going freaking crazy i
don't want to be one i denounce my
celebrities today
you know as as a world famous celebrity
i can relate
and also larry gadlin he still gets
recognized at the local police stations
because i do a lot of police benefits
yes and also the birthmark
you've seen it yes who has
he's got his own instagram account
but shaq's a guy who'd rather be
remembered for how he treats people not
what he's achieved which again is much
like me why just today my assistant made
eye contact with me and i didn't fire
her i think that inspired her to do
better in between her bouts of crying
but she's doing better than last week's
assistant
r.i.p
but we wish shaq luck in whatever he
does as long as it's not a sequel to
kazam
but i do have a theory as to why so many
celebs are jerks a lot of them go crazy
by age 35 because the time spent chasing
fame comes at a cost and the cost is
learning how to be a person fame and
power enables a-holes look no further
than the cuomo brothers right really
then when the when the fame evaporates
they realize they're just a vapid empty
shell a worse debra
messing you're hot tonight you are hot
tonight yeah yeah you know you're
sexually harassing me right now larry i
want to go tyrus uh i'm you know i'm
with shaq on this uh i've disowned my
celebrity i'm no longer going to be
flying first class i will be going
private but i'm not doing first class
what
what
you know
i i love shaq he's one of my favorite
people
just curious why you picked me
to lead this what was it was it was it
the height thing was it the athletic
background or was it something else
but you felt more comfortable asking me
to clear
you know kind of break the ice for you
so you can maybe make a joke afterwards
well i'm not gonna do that today greg
okay uh you know
the the thing that's great about shaq is
that he has never been thirsty yeah and
that term
is that you just need more because you
can't get enough of what you are he's
always kind of been
at a high level and he was there because
he worked hard even after i would say
his mba career isn't as powerful as what
he's done after his nba career he owns
businesses he helps people if everything
from he's a sheriff he's a sharer uh
yeah he's a debt he does a lot of things
and he doesn't do it for anyone else but
himself and the people he wants to do
well so he's in a position mentally
where he's not thirsty for fame because
if it's taken away from him he has
things most celebrities it's a short
life it's not very long so when they get
towards the end of it around 35-ish when
the new ones coming in they start
getting crazy that's why they all get
political right and they all do these
things and they all want to they want to
save the whales but still eat beluga so
they're just they're out of their
they're out of their mind because
they're just so damn thirsty and shaq's
not thirsty yeah you know uh cat it's
got to be hard for you to work with
someone this famous and selfless oh i'm
humble
yeah you're humble
but what so why does this show work cat
because we all get along in real life
no well that too i hate you well but no
that's what you want people to think but
you don't i don't know we don't have we
don't chase celebrities we beat we beat
kimmel we beat fallon we beat colbert
and
we don't have
we don't have
actors or actresses coming on to sell
products we don't care right because
once you start you kind of can't quit
yes because you're like when you become
an ass kisser you're an ass kisser
forever yeah
ass you cannot un-kiss an ass you can't
it's like ringing a bell well the well
you do the only time you have to stop
kissing an ass is when it's time for you
to kiss a new one yes
but the old one once you've given up
your principles of caring about
something more uh and just you know the
platform for platform's sake then you
can't go anywhere else because you've
lost your credibility and you're just
stuck to an ass yes
it's a human centipede of asses larry it
is larry you've been in in the spotlight
for some time and yet you haven't
changed at all
i'm not i'm not talking about your
internal organs i'm just talking about
you
uh
well i i hope you weren't being
facetious the here's the here's the
thing
an old friend of mine a great friend of
mine the late great daryl royal football
coach at the university of texas hook em
here's what daryl told me years ago
he said and he was a wise man he said
you can tell what kind of person someone
is
if you watch the way they treat people
who can't do anything for them
okay
every night when we leave the stage
after we've done our show i go out there
the stage crew's out there and i say and
they're the sound guys and i said hey
we could have done this without y'all
tonight
but we really would have to sing loud
okay
i can sing my ass off if the sound man
doesn't turn me up if he decides to
sabotage that
we all have people in our sphere and in
our circle who we need to depend on each
other that's what you judge there's no
room for me with the last word at this
point i mean okay here's the bottom line
yes shaquille o'neal has always done
things for other people and the fact
that he everybody knows who he is the
fact that he's the kind of guy who gets
all the attention he wants is an
indication that he is appreciative to
this country to what he's gotten from
this country to the fans in america to
the money that he's made in america he
understands where it all came from and
that's why he is giving up on the other
people who hate america hate the flag
can't stand us and you know what good
for shaq and the hell with the other
ones
all right
you know it reminds me so much of me
it's bizarre hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else